[Music]
one of the main reasons that i
took this view
that as i say the universe is a
succession of what i call eons
each of which begins with a big bang and
ends with the universe expanding
indefinitely
in this sort of way exponential
expansion that we seem to see
now
i've been troubled by something for many
many decades which is the second law of
thermodynamics which tells you that
things get more and more random as time
goes on
and this tells you that the big bang
ought to be very non-random
and one of the most
striking pieces of evidence for the
existence of the big bang
is what's called the microwave
background this is radiation
coming
electromagnetic radiation coming from
all directions
and one of the most striking features of
this radiation
is that it's in a maximum state of
entropy that is it's completely random
so it's a sort of puzzle where does all
this
run non-randomness come
if we're just presented with randomness
and i came to the conclusion that it has
to be in gravity that gravity has not
been taking part in this it's somehow
set as a very low value the entropy is
very low right at the beginning
and that means
for gravity it means it's very uniform
so this is a huge puzzle
why was gravity behaving differently
from other things and i worried about
this for a long time thinking that some
kind of quantum gravity would have to be
a very time asymmetrical theory and that
didn't work very well until i hit on
this idea
that the very remote expansion this
exponential expansion expands and
expands and expands
it gets colder and colder and colder and
less and less dense and black holes
most important things around eventually
evaporate away by walking evaporation it
just turns into eventually turns into
radiation there's nothing left
except it's all spread out when mata
is all spread out like this and it's
only
photons so it's mainly photons that's
particles which don't have any mass
they have no way of telling how big they
are so it's a mathematical thing but
when you don't have any mass big and
small are equivalent
so the remote future
the universe sort of forgets how big it
is that's a crazy idea of course but
that's the concept it doesn't really
know how big it is and what about the
big bang you see the big bang is really
the opposite it's really hot and very
dense and everything like that you think
what could be more different
but when you look at it carefully you
see the very hot particles running
around because they're moving around so
fast whatever mass they have it doesn't
even count the motion is the thing that
dominates so they in effect have no mass
either but both ends you have no mass
therefore neither end knows how big it
is now you've got to have some equations
to make sense of this but the idea is
the
expanded
previous eons i call it becomes our big
bang
now you have to make equations to make
that make sense this is the part that
people have great trouble swallowing
because it looks so different but when
you look at it from the
conformer point of view that big and
small
shapes make a lot of difference but
whether they're big shapes or small
shapes it doesn't make any difference
and if you that means from that
perspective the remote future looks like
a big man so it explains this puzzle i
had of the second world thermodynamics
and i don't think of any other theory
i've seen
explains
[Music]
you